Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai reçu une question d'Aurélie
qui me demande :
Quels sont les organismes qui oeuvrent dans l'activisme
féministe autochtone au Canada?
Pour commencer, Aurélie, il y a Femmes
autochtones du Canada, qui est un groupe
qui va unir tous les groupes
provinciaux de femmes autochtones.
Au Québec, on a la chance d'avoir
Femmes autochtones du Québec, qui est un groupe
extrêmement actif depuis 1976, qui aide
à la défense des droits des femmes autochtones,
qui va avoir aussi la capacité
d'aller dans les communautés,
de donner des ateliers de sensibilisation,
qui a même une voix auprès de l'APNQL
pour pouvoir aider à répondre aux
questions liées aux femmes auprès
des chefs des communautés.
C'est un organisme qui est très respecté
qui a même fait
de la représentation à l'ONU.
Les femmes se réunissent chaque année
et font vraiment en sorte que la cause
des femmes autochtones avance.
Ensuite, c'est certain qu'on a cette
question-là : Qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
les femmes en milieu urbain?
Parce qu'on pense souvent aux femmes en milieu
de communauté. Les femmes en milieu urbain,
elles, peuvent bénéficier des services
qui viennent des centres d'amitié autochtones.
À Montréal, on a deux centres d'amitié.
Il y a le centre d'amitié qu'on appelle
le Native Friendship Center et il y a aussi
le centre d'amitié qu'on appelle aussi
Montréal autochtone (Native Montreal).
Ces centres-là ont des cercles de femmes
qui, elles, peuvent aussi se mobiliser pour
pouvoir aider les femmes à s'unir,
à briser l'isolement, justement à défendre
des questions qui peuvent être plus
politique liée à habiter à Montréal.
Ces centres d'amitié se retrouvent un peu
partout dans les grands centres urbains
au Québec et font partie du grand
regroupement des centres
d'amitié autochtones.
Ce sont des groupes qui vont prendre
en charge la question des femmes
et souvent dans l'angle féministe autochtone.
C'est un angle qui est extrêmement
inclusif des hommes, des enfants,
des questions familiales.
Là, si on se retrouve au sein même des communautés,
il va y avoir même des cercles de couture,
des cuisines collectives,
des groupes d'aînées qui elles aussi vont
pouvoir travailler à régler
des questions féministes au sein des communautés.
Et quand on veut
encore aller plus loin,
on peut regarder des groupes
de mobilisation tel qu'Idle No More,
qui sont des groupes qui se sont unis
autour d'une idéologie féministe,
mais pour protéger l'environnement,
pour protéger justement les questions liées
au futur de nos enfants et à la protection
aussi des droits des hommes et des femmes.
Donc oui, il existe
beaucoup d'organismes
et il existe aussi beaucoup de groupes
qui s'unissent pour ces questions féministes,
mais c'est sûr que c'est d'un point de
vue des femmes autochtones et c'est des
points de vue qui se transforment grâce
aux alliances, grâce aux partenariats
qu'on fait avec des organismes non-autochtones.
J'espère, Aurélie, que ç'a répondu
à ta question.
J'espère que vous n'hésiterez pas
à nous envoyer d'autres questions
et à partager ce vidéo.
Je vous souhaite
une belle semaine.